[Music]
matt's in albuquerque new mexico hey
matt how are you
i'm doing fine uh thank you very much
dave and rachel for taking my call i
appreciate it sure what's up
i
i feel really uh kind of bad asking this
because so many people having a rough go
of it and suffering everything and yet
my question seems so you know success
does not cause their problems
well i appreciate that
anyway uh what i would like to know is
if i can get a uh objective answer to
the question of whether
i can afford or should uh purchase or
get into a golf club golf club
membership absolutely you should no i'm
kidding i was like this is a perfect
over there
that's like asking me if you should buy
it i mean come on
really i thought i'd have a better
chance if if i said gun club but anyway
any of these are good with me i'm good
with all of them so uh uh
all kidding aside uh
you know
obviously it's not a moral question it's
just a ratios thing
if it is a small enough percentage of
your life that it doesn't matter
mathematically then obviously you should
do it
if you're going to spend your kids
college tuition to join a golf club no
be a man don't do that
no it's it's not that uh the golf club
membership
um
in the initiation fee plus you know
getting the cart itself would run uh
thirty thousand dollars and then the uh
the monthly
uh dues after that
is
roughly 550 600 a month it's pretty
reasonable for most golf clubs
hopefully it's a decent track right
yeah it's it's a real nice it's a real
nice uh course yeah what do you make of
your community with it what do you make
of your uh
household income
is around 165 okay and what's your net
worth
uh including property and all of that
good stuff in the neighborhood of uh 1.5
million okay and you're debt-free
debt-free no mortgage no credit card no
nothing except monthly bills
matt i think you've just joined the
country club
[Laughter]
yeah i think you're fine yeah i think
you're fine
your only problem is you're still a
tight wad that's your only problem
see that yeah it kind of you know uh it
kind of hurt a little bit you know
because that's a lot of money for
initial outlay and there was a time you
know six months ago i cancelled an mp3
purchase because they had risen the
price from 99 cents to a dollar 29. so
you know i just that's just yeah that's
horrible i can't believe that they would
do that to a man like you but um and
matt i'm assuming too you're going to
use the membership correct like you
enjoy golfing you're going to be using
it it's not like oh i'm just going to do
it it's going to just sit there
and it's a waste you're going to be
using it yeah i'm not going to yeah i'm
not going to just say hey look what i
got no absolutely i'm going to be
hacking away so
matt that's the y'all are like throwing
out golf terms that i have no idea what
you mean so i'm assuming that's a golf
yeah i think it just means he's going to
dig holes in the golf course
yeah what i would encourage matt is that
you know we talk about here on the show
so often that you live like no one else
and that's what you hear a lot on the
show is the sacrifice that people are
taking
currently to get out of debt to build up
an emergency fund to get to a point
where their heads above water
but then to later to live and give like
no one else and so you're just at the
that other end of the equation and a lot
of people struggle
in that latter part of the equation
because they're like oh gosh like
yeah if spending money feels weird or i
feel wasteful is this okay they ask all
the same questions you ask and so um so
what i'm always looking for it to make
it a wise decision and also to make it
emotionally palatable is ratios
okay
how big a percentage of your world is
this and thirty thousand dollars is a
percentage of 1.5 or as a percent of 165
000 income with somebody completely debt
free it's like buying a biscuit dude
i mean it's not it's not gonna affect
your life
if you take thirty thousand dollars and
put it in the middle of the floor and
burn it
your life is not gonna change
no okay that's my point and so that
means you can afford this and it because
you don't even notice it doesn't affect
your giving it doesn't affect your
investing it affects your enjoyment of
life and it's there's three things you
can do with money you can enjoy it you
can give it and you can invest it and
you should always be doing all three but
look at the ratios
and the ratios set you free because i
used to be that guy i was that guy said
no one needs to drive a car that
expansive
because i'm like managing other people's
lives or something and that's just a
bunch of crap
that's just poor mouthing is what we
call it i mean that's just you grow up
in a neighborhood where you run down
rich people you know and it's like you
ain't seen every guy because who needs
to carry you ain't expensive i can tell
you who doesn't need it somebody can't
pay for it and that they notice when
they buy it but i got a friend that made
15 million dollars last year and he
drove it in front of my house in a 300
000 lamborghini
so but you know what that's a smaller
percentage he spent on his car of his
income than you spent on your car all of
you listening
so shut up
it's not yeah
none your business what he drives and
it's not affecting him it's a z it's a i
mean 300 000 a percent of 15 million so
if you make fifty 150
that'd be like minot uh a three thousand
dollar car
okay
the same exact ratios
so ex
so
you know he about shut up
you got a full-time job managing your
life
jeez
this great job matt touchdown i'm proud
of you go get the dadgum golf membership
you're awesome this is the ramsey show